are you left-handed if so one in ten
people around the world is like you
however 9 out of 10 people are
right-handed stone tools suggests that
most of our ancestors were like most of
us right-handed
it's hard to pin down when left
handedness started but we do have
evidence that they were left-handed
Neanderthals 500,000 years ago how do we
know this well they were probably eating
raw meat which is tough old stuff
archaeologists think the Neanderthals
would sink their teeth in and then use a
sharp piece of stone to cut the meat
near their mouth sometimes the stone
slipped and from the direction of the
scratches 10% of Neanderthals seem to
have held the cutter in their left hand
for right-handers it's normally the left
side of the brain that's associated with
speech and language what though if you
are left-handed just by using their left
hand for writing two-thirds of
left-handers are just like right-handers
in having language in their left brain
but 1/3 of left-handers have language in
the right side of their brain the
opposite of right-handers left-handers
are much more variable in the ways their
brains are organized in contrast
right-handers brains irv off the take
left handedness is therefore much more
of a mixture of strengths and weaknesses
pros and cons coming from having a
somewhat differently organized brain
it's your baby sucking its thumb
psychologist Peter Hepburn in Belfast
studied several hundred scans where the
baby in the womb was seen sucking its
thumb about 90 percent of babies sucked
their right thumb and at 12 years old
almost all of those right thumb suckers
were right-handed
whereas 3/4 of the left thumb suckers
will become left-handed genes are
clearly also important one left-handed
parent and you're more likely to be
left-handed yourself both parents
left-handed and you're even more likely
about a one in four chance
infants often go through a random
chaotic phase where the use of right
hand one day and the left the other
perplexing their parents by about two
years old their handedness is usually
consistent if you practice long and hard
enough then you can probably do anything
equally well with either hand concert
pianists are a good example though it
does take dedication in 1797 the
right-handed Admiral Lord Nelson had his
right elbow shattered by a musket ball
the arm was amputated
within six months though Nelson had
learned to write fluently with his left
hand but the motivation was there of
course professional sports players are
also motivated to practice as it can
give an added edge in competition
footballers trained to kick well with
either foot and when practicing they use
both feet confidently and well but under
pressure when the actions hot they often
revert to using their dominant foot even
if it means taking an extra half step
before shooting forego reversing your
natural sidedness does come with a cost
you could be almost equally good with
each hand or foot but the price would be
so much time practicing that you
probably wouldn't do anything else with
your life
the list of famous left-handers seems
pretty impressive
Howard Einstein Beethoven Bob Dylan
Picasso Neil Armstrong Winston Churchill
Benjamin Franklin Marilyn Monroe all the
claims on the internet to be left-handed
and in each case it's almost certainly
wrong the evidence of left handedness is
often very dodgy indeed for instance
this book for the painting of Beethoven
writing with his left hand the picture
has clearly been flipped there are many
reasons why people may wrongly claim
that famous individuals are left-handed
tribal loyalty and the reflected glory
of feeling part of the same hand in this
club are just two of them perhaps when
it comes down to it there is a little
bit of the left-hander in each of us
you